hello someone I'm Samuel leaves in this
video I'm going to be talking about how
to become financially free in 2020 even
if you were starting with non or very
little money so one of the strategies
that people have been scared of over the
last couple few months is a strategy
that previously helped hundreds of
people become financially free and that
strategy is went to rent combined with
serviced accommodation went to rent is
very simply when you find a property off
of the landlord and you give them a
guaranteed rent you do it under the
correct management agreement not a nasty
under a management agreement you give
them a fixed guaranteed rent and then
you list the property on Airbnb you list
it on booking.com
and then you rent it out per night when
you rent it out per night what happens
is you get a super rent so you're giving
the landlord a fixed monthly guaranteed
rent you're renting it on a super rent
this is called went to rent and the
difference between the rent and the
super end is yours and so many of my
students over the last two three years
have become financially independent from
this strategy now some of the cons of
this strategy of course are that you
have to find the property that there's
things to do this is not get rich quick
this is become financially free in 2020
now here's the problem
bom-bom-bom the problem is that serviced
accommodation ie when you list the
property on booking.com on Airbnb during
lockdown became impossible because
hotels weren't allowed to trade hotels
weren't allowed to rent their own rooms
out so I mean some people have a
surviving but joyluck nights been really
really hard because booking.com haven't
been taking bookings serviced
accommodation has basically been very
very difficult during lockdown as a
result of that people have handed their
keys back to the landlord people have
fleed from the idea of rental serviced
accommodation people have been scarred
in their brains from the idea of having
a property where they're paying a
monthly guaranteed rent but they can't
rent it out themselves however
when people are scared you should be
greedy observe the masses and do the
opposite what's happening now lockdowns
lifting what's happening is very very
very very soon
hotels are going to start opening again
and booking calm are going to start
taking bookings and a B and B's gonna
start taking bookings and all these
landlords that have been handed their
keys back in a lot oh no I liked my
guaranteed went hello what's the thing
to do I would suggest rent to serviced
accommodation is the thing to do so over
the next four to six weeks what would I
suggest you do you learn you strategize
you find your area you start speaking to
landlords in about four six weeks
take the contract on lot nouns lifted
Hotel opened boom
the average serviced accommodation rent
around property in Britain will make you
a profit of between 500 and 1,000 pounds
per month how many of those do you need
to replace your job for five you can do
that in the next six months that's my
suggestion if you've got questions about
this strategy comment them below I'm
also gonna be running a webinar very
soon about this exact strategy so in the
description box there'll be a little bit
more information on this free webinar
I'm going to be running check it out
book on the webinar I look forward to
seeing you become financially free and
interviewing you on my youtube channel
where we can share the success in about
six months time thank you for watching
smash the like one drop a comment
subscribe turn the notification belt on
that's all asking you right now
peace out see you next time